merci d'être là madame priseur du
plaisir
bon on va d'abord rappelé que c'est ce
jour du dépassement et commence à ce
calcul juste un peu controversé comme
calcul cole john wayne oui tout à fait
alors le jour du dépassement c'est le
jour partir duquel vit au dessus de nos
moyens qui veut ça se calcule assez
simplement bien que ce sans calcul qui
soit controversé comme vous l'avez dit
qu'en fait on prend on compare deux
éléments ont par l'empreinte écologique
de la population c'est à dire combien il
nous faut par pays par personne pour
produire des céréales produire du bois
pour combien d'océan il nous faut pour
avoir des poissons
quelle surface nous faut également pour
compenser les déchets qui sont
engendrées de notre consommation et pour
compenser les gaz à effet de serre qui
sont générés par cette consommation
donc ça c'est l'empreinte écologique et
on nous parle cette notion là avec la
notion de bio capacité c'est-à-dire la
capacité en fait de la terre à offrir à
produire des ressources qui sont
renouvelables et à pouvoir absorber les
déchets qui en sont bien en résulte
alors au client un calcul entre les deux
et on arrive à déterminer le calcul le
jour du dépassement et le calcul vont
comme quoi qu'il soit controversé nous
indique quand même que depuis les années
70 on vit toujours à crédit
et d'ailleurs la dernière fois qu'on
était aux veines de où c'était un
2004-2006 denquin théorie à chaque année
le jour du dépassement de la terre
survient de plus en plus tôt mais cette
année c'est repoussé cette année c'est
repoussé cette année on gagnerait 3
semaines alors selon les calculs
officiels selon les nouveaux moyens de
calculer ce jour du dépassement qui
changent d'année en année on arrive à ce
type de résultat est effectivement cette
année on aurait gagné trois semaines ce
qui veut pas dire que avec une
éventuelle reprise à la rentrée ou au
mois de novembre décembre les calculs ne
change pas tout à fait mais on dépasse
même actuellement même avec les mesures
de confinement qui ont été mises en
place on dépasse largement ce qu'on ne
peut se permettre
oui bah ça c'est clair on est tout de
même un déficit mais c'est encore par
andrée 22 ou la dernière fois qu'on
était à cette date là c'était en 2004 à
2006 on peut donc pas dire qu'on a gagné
15 ans et on veut pas exactement ça se
passe comme ça non on a gagné du temps
si on veut on consomme moins ce qui est
intéressant ici c'est que aujourd'hui en
terme de population on est beaucoup plus
nombreux que ce qu'on était en 2004 2006
les moyens de calculer l'empreinte
écologique les moyens de produire de
l'électricité sont différencie donc
c'est passé très facile de dire qu'on a
gagné 15 ans ouais mais tout de même on
observe que c'est repoussé les faits par
des mickeys ce qui explique ça c'est
quand on consomme moins il ya moins de
pollution quels sont les facteurs
alors effectivement on consomme moins on
consomme beaucoup plus à la maison
combat mon restaurant
on prend nettement moins l'avion alors
il ya des chiffres qui sont quand même
assez important dans ce domaine là
certaines statistiques montrent que
justement
le transport aérien a été pratiquement
arrêté 81 98 % des activités aériennes
ont été arrêtés au mois de mai par
rapport aux activités du mois de mai
l'année passée donc c'est quand même
très important puisque c'est un impact
important sur sur les gaz à effet de
serre et donc sur l'empreinte écologique
l'empreinte forestière aussi ou nappe
est beaucoup moins d'arbres parce qu'il
y avait une demande bien moins
importante pour le bois de construction
puisqu'il est tous les chantiers de
construction ont été arrêtés aussi donc
ça c'est un impact aussi important en
terme de d'énergie on parle beaucoup du
charbon c'est en fait le charbon c'est
[Musique]
l'élément qui a été le plus regardé au
début de la pandémie parce qu'on a vu on
regarde et la chine beaucoup puisque la
chine nous a servi un peu d'exemple si
on veut on a vu que dans d'autres pays
qui utilisaient charbon les résultats
étaient les mêmes donc s importante du
charbon mais pas seulement
on peut observer des résultats
similaires avec d'autres types
d'électricité on le voit puisque de
nombreuses entreprises organisations ont
dû arrêter ralentir ou carrément cessé
leur activité
les besoins en énergie ont été ont été
drastiquement réduit donc on peut
attribuer la baisse de l'empreinte
écologique si on veut de cette année à
ces éléments
sauf que ça dans ton ceux d'autres bien
madame fraser c'est que ces gars là sont
temporaires n'est ce pas c'est bien là
son temporaire puisque on peut
s'attendre à une reprise de l'activité
économique à la rentrée et puis l'année
prochaine puisque comme vous le savez
les gouvernements de cesse que de
vouloir reprendre ce qui a été perdu
puisque c'est quelque chose qui est une
façon pensiez qui est assez courante
aujourd'hui
et quand on voit que certains pays comme
la chine par exemple reprennent leurs
activités économiques
quand on voit que d'autres pays comme la
russie et autres ont trouvé des moyens
de reprendre leur activité est certain
que au canada et ailleurs la volonté
sera la même donc vous attendre à une
reprise d'activité on peut s'apprendre
peut s'attendre aussi à une empreinte 60
ouais bon alors malheureusement on
risque de revoir cette journée du
dépassement possiblement juillet dès
l'an prochain on va surveiller ça madame
priseur merci beaucoup pour vos
explications
merci se protéger